so this whole embarrassing walking and
talk all the camera think it's
relatively new to me but I am getting
out from the office today and going to
midtown Manhattan to one of my favorite
New York wonders and to visit with my
longtime friend and fellow youtuber
Jonathan Mann and holy crap is this
tiring for your arms so we're here in
Grand Central Station this is my buddy
Jonathan Mann also known as song a day
man because he's been making a song a
day for seven years which is insane you
also might know him actually from this
video
and we are here to explore one of grand
Central's great acoustic wonders we are
going to the lower concourse because
we're here for the Whispering Gallery in
the Whispering Gallery and behaves
really differently here
you might notice actually there's no one
in the corner behind us that's because
you can stand across from each other in
this 30-foot span and basically speak
directly to each other like you were
standing next to one another we're gonna
test the Whispering Gallery of Grand
Central Terminal with a song that
Jonathan composed specifically for this
okay so into our corners we go so
Jonathan is going to his corner and I am
going to mine Jonathan can you hear me
okay
great I can hear you too he in free
space sound dissipates as a proportion
to the square of the distance from the
source veneer and our surface the sound
different plants proportionally
dissipating from the sound of Han
which means that it dissipates slower
and I can sing quiet over here and over
there this camera picks me up
totally loud and clear whispering ways
Whispering Gallery no tiles
just in the time that we have been here
doing this this this duet so many people
have come and done done this exact thing
and the kind of childlike wonder that
people have when they realize that it
works is is like wonderful to behold so
to check out Jonathan man's incredible
song add a channel click here and hear
the Whispering Gallery song in its
entirety click here and I will leave you
with some examples of Gustav Eno tiles
with Jonathan Mann as musical
accompaniment